una votación que parecía interminable
hasta la madrugada de este miércoles los
155 convencionales realizaron ocho
rondas de votación para escoger al
próximo presidente o presidenta de la
convención encargada de redactar la
nueva carta magna de chile sin embargo
ninguno de los candidatos logró reunir
los 78 votos necesarios para sustituir a
elisa loncón la actual presidenta y nos
damos cuenta allí construir la
democracia implica tiempo porque implica
nuevo implicaría un nuevo año el mismo
feudo inaugural en los resultados de la
votación del martes la candidata por los
movimientos sociales constituyentes
cristina dorador quedó a la cabeza con
51 votos seguida de benito baranda con
37 votos sin embargo poco después del
anuncio dorador retiró su candidatura
con el objetivo de destrabar la votación
tenemos que tomar una decisión tenemos
que avanzar
y este paso como paso importante la
renovación de la mesa forma parte de los
compromisos democráticos que asumimos
frente al pueblo de chile lo prolongado
de la votación se debe tanto a la falta
de acuerdos como al sistema manual de
elección y conteo que ralentiza aún más
el proceso -cada convencional debe
levantarse en cada ronda para depositar
su voto que son contados posteriormente
uno a uno por la mesa directiva la
convención va contrarreloj tiene hasta
junio para terminar de redactar la nueva
carta magna que deberá ser aprobada en
un plebiscito para su entrada en vigor
la actual constitución fue inspirada
durante la dictadura militar su cambio
fue uno de los acuerdos pactados para
solucionar la crisis de 2019 en la que
se registraron protestas que dejaron 30
muertos